alors expliquez à noter les spectateurs
c'est qu'en fait vous contrôler que les
personnes sont sont bien malades quand
elles voilà j'ai une entreprise qui est
spécialisée dans les contrôles de
d'arrêt de travail qui me missionne pour
aller vérifier que les arrêts de travail
sont justifiés ou parfois non mais je
dois dire quand en général ils sont 9
fois sur 10 ils sont justifiés c'est ça
c'est exceptionnel là
vous faites un contrôle
sur cet homme c'était en plein mois
d'août au début qui voulait qui vous
envoyez chez lui c'est la société donc
qui vous travaillez c'est une société
oui qui m'a missionné pour aller
contrôler l'arrêt de travail de cette
personne qui habitait dans le centre de
Nice
une personne tout à fait classique vous
connaissiez pas du tout c'est que je
connaissais pas du tout je n'ai pas du
tout de lien non plus ni avec le
l'entreprise qui se missionne qui
demande vous allez directement chez le
chez le chez moi je suis totalement
indépendant je viens voir et je demande
des explications sur la raison de
l'arrêt de travail en fait je demande de
quelle maladie souffre ça s'était
toujours bien passé avant ça se passe
toujours bien exceptionnellement parfois
les gens sont un petit peu agressifs
parce que ça leur plaît pas qu'on vienne
contrôler leur arrêt de travail comment
ça se passe vous tapez directement aux
portes vous devez je vais à l'adresse je
sonne et n'importe quoi vous prévenez
pas bien entendu il y a des heures de où
ils sont obligés d'être chez eux en
principe quoi d'accord bah oui c'est
normal donc 11h
il m'arrive assez fréquemment que les
hommes ne soient pas chez eux c'est ça
alors ça je sais pas ce qui se passe
exactement voilà bon là il se trouve que
la personne était chez lui vous allez
contrôler donc cet homme
vous arrivez vous sonnez qu'est-ce qui
vous dit déjà dit il ouvre apparemment
il était paradis de me voir
je lui explique pour la raison pour
laquelle je viens boire habituellement
les personnes me laissent entrer chez
eux pour que je puisse m'asseoir et
écrire quelque chose là il a refusé que
je puisse entrer j'ai dit pas de
problème on va moi-même m'expliquer ça
sur le palier de la porte sur le palier
de la porte sur le palier voilà bon donc
je vais demander les de son arrêt de
travail et tout de suite il s'est mis en
colère en m'expliquant que son patron
était moins que rien qui c'est un je
sais pas s'il m'a dit le terme bandit
mais enfin c'était plus ou moins un
escroc et que il respectait rien dans
les règles de travail etc alors j'ai
essayé de le calmer en disant monsieur
moi je suis pas dans l'entreprise je ne
sais pas comment ce qui se passe avec
votre employeur peut-être que vous avez
raison qu'il se comporte mal votre
employeur mais moi je suis là pour voir
savoir si vous êtes malade exactement un
arrêt maladie c'est quand on est malade
toujours sur le pain de la porte donc là
et donc là au début on a l'impression
qu'il se confie à vous qui vous dit
voilà moi je voilà la plupart du temps
ça se passe très bien les gens
m'expliquent il y a une relation je leur
donne même parfois des conseils voilà
quand je fais dans mon cabinet mais là
il était vraiment très très en colère
vis-à-vis de son patron et je pense ce
qui est dommage c'est que c'est souvent
les personnes qu'on contrôle
l'impression qu'on est le représentant
du patron ce qui était pas du tout le
cas parce que moi je le connais pas le
patron et puis je je n'ai aucun intérêt
à aller dans un sens ou dans l'autre
j'essaie d'être objectif de dire je
pense qu'en général 9 fois sur dix la
règle justifiée de temps en temps il
n'est pas c'était le cas c'était le cas
vous avez senti que ça n'était pas le
cas ça oui je lui ai expliqué que le
fait d'être en colère contre son patron
même si son patron n'était pas très
correct celle justifie pas n'arrêt
maladie fait ça parce que là je suis un
noir s'il est malade ou pas et il était
pas mais il était simplement en colère
la colère pour moi vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas malade voilà exactement
en pleine forme
maladie n'est pas justifié je lui ai
expliqué que j'étais désolé parce que
c'est toujours embêtant de contrarié les
gens mais que moi je pouvais pas
justifier son arrêt maladie alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce que on a
vu les photos derrière qui nous ont
bouleversé je vous dis docteur vraiment
comment là on a l'impression que c'est
une discussion assez courtoise voilà il
se confie à vous comment ça a basculé
dans cette violence
il y a toujours une grande tension de
son côté il restait sur la colère
vis-à-vis de son patron et j'ai pas
réussi à les faire comprendre que moi
j'avais rien à voir avec son patron il
me confondait un peu avec son patron
donc à chaque fois on est obligé en
entreprise nous demande de tendre un
document à la personne comme quoi on est
bienvenu le contrôler et malheureusement
on doit leur dire lui dire notre notre
avis si on est d'accord avec la raie ou
pas et là j'ai dit Monsieur maintenant
il faudrait que vous signiez le document
comme quoi je suis venu vous voir et que
j'ai constaté que votre arène n'était
pas justifiée il m'a arraché le papier
des mains et là il immédiatement il m'a
envoyé un percute un coup de poing dans
le dans le visage direct donc j'étais
très très surpris moi je m'attendais pas
à ça c'est pas c'est ça n'arrive jamais
cette histoire là parfois j'ai eu
quelques insultes de la part des
dans l'occasion d'un contrôle mais enfin
jamais
on est arrivé à la violence j'avais
jamais j'aurais jamais imaginé ça quoi
donc là beaucoup de points direct j'ai
même pas eu le temps de savoir ce qui
m'arrivait et puis non seulement il me
met un coup près mais il m'a tabassé
comme moi je pensais qu'il voulait me
tuer sincèrement la façon dont ils jeter
sur moi donc ça a basculé
instantanément d'une seconde à l'autre
que dire il est passé de la colère à une
espèce de furie je ne sais pas j'ai eu
très peur parce que je vais me tuer ce
type là j'ai pas les moyens de me
défendre je suis pas je suis pas habitué
à bagarrer en plus je suis pas un
bagarreur et donc heureusement dieu
merci nous étions sur le panier que
j'étais pas chez lui mais si j'avais été
chez lui c'est parce qu'il m'aurait fait
et en plus on était au rez-de-chaussée
donc là donc là il s'y attire sur vous
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il vous achète il
m'a donné des coups de poing de partout
il m'a arraché la peau de la main il m'a
fait une ouverture au visage et eu cette
Point de Suture j'ai eu des côtes fêlées
j'avais mal partout ça a duré combien de
temps ça a duré quelques quelques
petites minutes parce que j'ai réussi à
m'enfuir dans la rue à ce que même avec
lui qui me courait derrière en de me
tabasser heureusement dans la rue il y
avait quelques passants dont un passant
qui était assez courageux puisqu'il
s'est interposé il était assez costaud
donc et là l'autre l'agresseur c'est
calmé quand même
il m'a pas couru après parce qu'il y
avait la personne entre nous deux je me
suis éloigné le plus vite possible à ce
moment-là mais il continue à m'insulter
de loin dans la dans la colère de
l'arrivait pas à se maîtriser le passant
dieu merci a eu la chance d'appeler la
police immédiatement avec son portable
qui est arrivé dans les cinq dix minutes
il est très très rapidement donc là on a
vu votre état qu'est-ce que vous êtes
dit à ce moment-là vous êtes dit va me
tuer comme vous assure le moment j'étais
en train de me tuer ce type là
c'était évident de dire il s'acharnait
sur moi comme mais qu'est-ce qu'il vous
disait
terme exactement
espèce de du ferait mieux de
prendre ta retraite plutôt que
d'emmerder les gens faire des choses
comme ça quoi de dire très très
agressif insultant très insultant c'est
des insultes ce qui est fou c'est la
c'est c'est la bascule entre voilà la
discussion que vous avez au début et là
quand cet acharnement sur vous donc là
la police arrive vous êtes dans un
piteux état
je me suis la police est arrivé donc je
me suis je suis parti me rendre aux
urgences de la Vienne clinique pas très
loin je suis allé à la clinique comme
recoudre donc ça a été quoi les
séquelles
pendant plusieurs semaines surtout mal
au coach j'avais mal à la mâchoire aussi
j'arrivais difficilement à marcher m'a
mangé pardon marchait ça allait encore
et puis voilà des douleurs un peu
partout puis surtout j'étais très très
inquiet parce que je me disais ce type
là comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
le procureur a demandé ce qui se
regardait alors justement parce que là
la police arrive qu'est-ce qui se passe
il interpelle il interprète il emmène
tout de suite et puis il était en garde
à vue je sais pas 24 heures ou 48 heures
et le donc le procureur a demandé qu'il
soit gardé en garde à vue en attendant
une expertise psychiatrique parce que on
sait pas ce qui se passait dans sa tête
et donc
le juge a décidé qu'il leur mettait en
liberté ça j'ai pas compris du tout
parce que ça c'est incroyable à 21h06
écoutez moi je comprends pas Jean-Yves
franchement je vous dis moi j'ai vu j'ai
vu votre vélo photo j'ai vu votre état
je vous jure j'ai pensé à vous tous j'ai
passé un mauvais quart d'heure ça c'est
encore plus en rigoler aujourd'hui j'en
non mais menacées
je pense que vous avez eu très très
échappé belle quoi tu as vu très très
peur
il est en garde à vue qu'est-ce qui se
passe après parce que c'est ça qu'on a
envie de savoir donc là il vous roue de
cou pour rien voilà donc
aucune excuse
et qu'est-ce qui se passe après ah ben
moi je n'en sais rien moi je j'attendais
d'avoir des nouvelles d'une expertise
psychiatrique bien sûr ouais tu as un
petit peu peut-être rassuré je sais pas
savoir qu'est-ce qui se passait dans la
tête de cet individu
tellement colérique c'est quand même
inquiétant quoi mais moi je dirais c'est
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité parce
que cet événement
je m'incite à penser qu'on est dans une
société qui qui tolère la violence
finalement qu'il a banalise quelque part
c'est on a l'impression que c'est un peu
normal chacun fait son coup de poing
c'est incroyable parce que on a la
chance que vous soyez là aujourd'hui
mais je vous dis
ça aurait pu être beaucoup plus grave
et les coûts qui vous a saigné
je tombais par terre une fracture du
crâne je peux rester sur le carreau quoi
il hémorragie cérébrale